[Musica]
era l'estate del 1645 a delft in olanda
un venditore di tessuti anthony vanden
dal cognome abbastanza impronunciabile
si reca un lago presso casa sua e
riempie una piccola bottiglia d'acqua
anthony è una persona che ha la passione
per la scienza per il mondo naturale
questa scampagnata al lago pensate
sancirà la nascita di una nuova
disciplina scientifica la microbiologia
tanto importante anche ai giorni nostri
anthony è davvero considerato il padre
della microbiologia perché è stato lui a
scoprire a studiare a osservare ea
descrivere per la prima volta quelli che
noi oggi comunemente chiamiamo micro vip
anthony osservò nell'acqua del lago una
miriade di oggetti di particelle batteri
alghe particelle varie non sapeva però
bene come chiamarle alla fine quando
decise di scrivere questa relazione da
inviare alla royal society of london li
chiamo animaletti qualche anno dopo con
lo stesso microscopio perché il bello
era che anthony il microscopio si
ricostruiva da se erano molto semplici
costituita da una singola lente ma molto
potenti riuscì addirittura a
visualizzare con il microscopio il
flusso di gruppi rosse all'interno di
capillari delle rane confermando così le
prime teorie sulle circolazioni del
sangue di marcello malpighi infatti
anche nel sangue esistono innumerevoli
particelle pensate che in un all
organismo adulto umano si producono 250
miliardi di globi rossi in un giorno 15
miliardi di globuli bianchi e 500
miliardi di piastrine un mare di
particelle in una giornata tersa bella
come quella di oggi nessuno
immaginerebbe mai che siamo immersi in
una miriade di particelle in realtà
nell'atmosfera esistono tantissime
particelle sia di origine naturale che
di origine antropica pollini aerosol
marino frammenti vegetali sabbie oppure
purtroppo di origine antropica dovuto ai
processi di combustione processi
industriali o per esempio all'usura
dell'asfalto o dei freni delle nostre
automobili
però è anche vero che senza le
particelle non potremo beneficiare dei
meravigliosi colori dell'alba o dei
tramonti perché le particelle sono loro
che scatta erano la luce e quindi ci
consentono di osservare questi colori am
vorremmo che ci fossero però soltanto
particelle salubri per la salute
ma passiamo alle acque anche all'interno
delle acque più limpide trasparenti uno
non immagina che ci sia un brulicare
continuo di particelle per esempio
esiste la cosiddetta neve marina la neve
marina è costituita da particelle che
più o meno velocemente al raggiungono le
profondità degli oceani portando con sé
la vita sostanze organiche
ebbene queste particelle portano con sé
anche co2 l'anidride carbonica
contribuendo quindi al sequestro
dell'anidride carbonica negli oceani e
in qualche modo medicando l'effetto
serra
le microalghe che producono una parte
significativa dell'ossigeno all'interno
della nostra atmosfera
le microalghe per esempio sono alla base
della catena alimentare i gamberetti si
cibano di microalghe i pesci mangiano i
gamberetti e così via
quindi in qualche modo ogni elemento che
turba l'equilibrio o il numero di albi
all'interno degli oceani può causare
quindi una crisi dell'ecosistema minando
alla base la sua sostenibilità ma
dall'altro ogni elemento che perturba
gli oceani e magari produce un
incremento delle armi e del cosiddetto
fioriture o audio al bloom come si
direbbe in inglese in qualche modo crea
dei danni all'economia anche alla salute
dell'uomo quindi vedete che in tutti gli
esempi che vi sto prospettando l'area le
acque il mare ma anche all'interno del
sangue esistano milioni di particelle e
sorprendente riflettere sul fatto che
particelle tante piccole possono avere
un'influenza sulla vita del pianeta e
sulle nostre vite
in definitiva sistemi non non in
equilibrio possono cambiare le
prospettive del nostro pianeta
la gran parte di queste particelle
pensate a dimensioni che vanno da un
decima un centesimo della sezione di un
nostro capello che di circa 100 micro
guarda caso più o meno il range di
misura delle particelle di intervallo di
misura delle particelle che ritroviamo
nel sangue come globi rossi con cui
bianchi o le piastrine hanno delle
dimensioni talmente piccole che uno non
direbbe che potrebbero in maniera
significativa avere un impatto sul
pianeta di fatto invece possono avere
un'influenza violenta
finora non vi ho parlato delle
microplastiche ovviamente le micro
plastiche sono di produzione umana
la maggior parte vengono fuori dai
lavaggi in lavatrice dei capi sintetici
dall usura dei pneumatici dalle buste
bottiglie che irresponsabilmente spesso
disperdiamo dell'ambiente sono già
entrati nella catena alimentare e si
confondono infatti nel plancton e quindi
noi mangiamo i pesci e a quel punto
rischiamo di ingerire anche
microplastiche nemico prassi che si
trovano nel sale da cucina nell'acqua
che beviamo quindi a me e da un po di
tempo che stiamo inserendo qui queste
microplastiche ma quali sono le
conseguenze ancora non ci sono studi
precisi sull'effetto delle micro
classiche sul corpo umano possono essere
pericolose possono creare tumori possono
rilasciare sostanze chimiche all'interno
dell'organismo quindi vedete che è
necessario sviluppare strumenti e
metodologie per capire queste particelle
che formano di che materiale sono fatte
come si muovono interagiscono diciamo
tra di loro per essere sicuri che il
pianeta in qualche modo mantiene un suo
equilibrio ed è interessante mantenere
questa analogia per esempio tra pianeta
e corpo umano
spesso si parla di equilibrio in salute
del corpo umano del pianeta c'è questa
imprescindibile influenza del mondo
microscopico con il mondo macroscopico
ma perchè vi sto parlando di particelle
la cosa curiosa è che qualche anno fa in
un'intervista un giornalista di un
quotidiano di importanza nazionale mi
affibbiò il l'appellativo di cacciatore
di particelle sulle prime questa questo
appellativo non era piaciuto ma forse ci
aveva preso era riuscito a identificare
essenzialmente diciamo e riassumere la
mia attività scientifica che svolgo il
mio gruppo nel consiglio nazionale di
ricerche di pozzuoli essenzialmente da
un po di anni dove andiamo a caccia di
particelle anomale all'interno del
sangue e qual è la nostra arma per fare
questa caccia un microscopio un
microcosmo speciale che si chiama
olografico è speciale perché ha un
occhio tridimensionale che è in grado di
dirci maggiori informazioni riguardo a
queste particelle
attraverso questo microscopio noi siamo
in grado di rappresentare tutte le più
minute caratteristiche morfologiche di
cellule per esempio lo globuli del
sangue o anche cellule tumorali per
questo andiamo a caccia di queste
cosiddette cellule tumorali circolanti
infatti purtroppo è noto che da un
tumore si staccano cellule intere
porzioni di esse che entrano in circolo
nel nostro sangue ben prima di quanto
possa essere diagnosticato con i sistemi
moderni la presenza di un tumore
quindi la vera sfida è quella di andare
a caccia di queste particelle cioè di
queste cellule tumorali all'interno del
sangue lo stesso microscopio utilizzato
per andare a caccia di cellule tumorali
può essere utilizzato per la diagnostica
nell'ecosistema marino infatti con il
microscopio tridimensionale è possibile
visualizzare le diatomee le diatomee
sono delle alghe del carroccio di nate
circa 645 milioni di anni fa e
rappresentano abbiamo detto
un'importante risorsa per tutto lui che
sistema marino ma anche per tutto il
pianeta
essenzialmente attraverso il microscopio
e noi siamo in grado di andare a vedere
la parte esterna il flusso ma anche la
parte interna il cloroplasto in presenza
di sostanze inquinanti nei mari il
colore plasto riduce o varie le sue
dimensioni attraverso questo microscopio
speciale è possibile misurare
precisamente queste variazioni quindi in
qualche modo attraverso il microscopio è
possibile ricavare la presenza o meno di
inquinanti e le diatomee vengono
utilizzate come sentinelle marine
a questo punto quindi vedete che questo
microscopio potrà dare una mano a
pianeta e anche al nostro corpo cellule
tumorali ambiente marino
ma quale sarà lo scenario futuro come
possiamo immaginare le prossime aeree
diciamo per salvare il nostro pianeta
per capire se queste patologie se questa
malattia pur regredire possono essere
trovate delle soluzioni essenzialmente
degli scenari possono essere per esempio
questi microscopi molto piccoli a bordo
di sciami di sottomarini senza guida con
guida come si dice autonoma che
esplorano gli oceani e in qualche modo
sono in grado di dare un monitoraggio
continuo degli abissi e dei mari
la nostra arma il nostro microscopio
potrà essere molto utile per la diagnosi
non solo delle malattie nel corpo umano
ma anche per il monitoraggio
dell'ecosistema marino
ma è importante non solo identificare
come abbiamo fatto vedere la forma le
dimensioni la densità la tipologia di
particelle anche importante vedere il
contesto nel quale queste particelle di
vero e operano per esempio all'interno
dell'ecosistema marino importante le
particelle capire dove sono le
particelle all'interno della colonna
d'acqua all'ora come si potrà vedere
diciamo in futuro uno scenario per
consentire a questi microscopici di dare
una mano al pianeta per salvarlo e per
poter in qualche modo diciamo definire
nuovi scenari
una possibilità è quella di montare dei
piccoli e microscopi a bordo di sciami
di piccoli sottomarina guidatore che
fanno un monitoraggio continuo
all'interno delle profondità e mandano
questi dati a centri di raccolta per i
ricercatori
un'altra possibilità è quella di
agganciare dei piccoli microscopi a
degli smartphone e quindi milioni di
pazienti potranno da casa a farsi
l'analisi è capire se ci sono anomale
all'interno del loro sangue così via
un come ultimo scenario si può
immaginare anche che un domani
microscopi piccolissimi possano
addirittura viaggiare all'interno del
corpo umano come in fantastiche boia di
un famoso film del 1966 quindi in
qualche modo la fantascienza fra un po
di della scienza grazie allo sviluppo
delle nuove tecnologie
vorrei concludere con una frase di maria
montessori quest'anno ricorre il
centocinquantesimo dalla sua nascita
aveva già intuito che purtroppo il mondo
è stato lacerato e ha bisogno di essere
ricostruito
[Musica]